I've sometimes wondered this about you
because especially
like you know you guys have released a
vlog now for three 3 weeks and just like
every time I watch the Vlog I'm just
like wow this guy is Relentless and in
my mind I'm thinking you've already made
the money you've already had the success
you've got the the biggest podcast in
the world like what are you doing it
for um so the reason I pause is because
it's very easy to and I don't
want to but it's also hard to
know the answer yeah and I think most of
us we get used to giving an answer to
that question but what I care a lot
about whether it's true or not and so I
think if I was to Hazard a guess at the
truth I would say it's a multitude of
reasons I would say on one hand there's
no greater feeling than doing something
that people appreciate and adds value to
someone else's life there's no feeling
like the feeling I experienced this
morning when I walked into the office
and the girl that grabbed me and said I
just quit my job literally this morning
I just quit my job and I told my boss in
that to interview why I was quitting and
it's because of your podcast I'm listen
to this particular guest and they help
me with this thing there's no metric
that actually feels like as good for the
human being as that the ego might love
oh we hit three million sub million
subscribers it's funny I walked into my
team that day and go I realize none of
us care that we hit 3 million
subscribers I also don't care it's
important that we use this as a metric
to understand that we've done we've done
well as a team but I realize none of us
care because we're like fing we're
figing caring who cares if you hit 3
million subscribers it's one more than
two 2 million 9 it's but it's nice to
have Milestones where we celebrate that
matters to me it matters to me that
we're creating stuff that's helping
people that really matters to me on the
other end I do look at the metrics all
the time as I know you do or at least
you did yeah I stop now okay okay we had
a conversation where you you I remember
very vividly you telling me that you
were like you used to be like really
obsessed with it all and it wasn't
wasn't great it
wasth so that's important that I do I
still have a bit of that in me where
like it matters to me how the episodes
perform in terms of numbers I don't know
I don't know why but um it does I want
the episodes to do really well and I
want I want things to grow and move
forward and get bigger I want that um
maybe that's the shame like the the kid
again trying to be enough um why am I
doing it I believe in life to be happy
you have to kind of fulfill these five
objectives in your profession number one
you need challenge right things need to
be become incrementally more difficult
to the level of appetite that you can
take that's why game in game psychology
every level gets harder you you're not
going to do the same cross word on the
same difficulty over and over again you
would lose motivation Daniel pink his
book is behind you says this they they
do it in studies if it's the same
difficulty people lose motivation so
when you're building teams the the thing
you've got to know as a sier as a
Founder is the depth of difficulty that
every single member of your team is at
and if at one point one of your team
members isn't challenged enough they
will quit you're about 6 months from
them asking for a meeting okay so keep
them one foot out of their depth and I
have this mental model in my head of all
my team members and I actually sat here
this morning with one of them this
morning at uh 9:00 a.m. this morning who
I knew was too comfortable and my
conversation with her this morning was
give me 48 hours I'm going to return you
to the state you were when we working
together in New York where you out of
your depth because I know that's what
you need she didn't articulate that to
me but I know it is I know the reason
why she's like feeling this is a one of
my companies one of my one of my
companies is because she's not out of
her depth anymore Factor number two to
be motivated and enjoy your work
is uh what I call the progress principle
sense of Forward Motion it's one of the
laws in the book as well when they
interview people in work and say what's
your best day in work Harvard Business
Review found it was when it was on days
where people had a sense of progress
this is also what David bford speaks to
um when he in entered the British
cycling team many people think of Sir
David bford who took over that down
andout British cycling team and made
them the best to ever do it they
attribute the success of that to the
fact that he cared about these 1%
marginal gains 100% that is a huge part
of it but what said David bord said to
me which I actually think is more
important because it's the macro
Tailwind is when we found those 1% gains
those small ways to improve something
making the water bottle 1 cm bigger the
pillow
softer the important part was the impact
it had on people's motivation because
quote we felt like we were going
somewhere humans need that sense of
we're going somewhere so if you're a CEO
one of the most important things you
should always do which I try and do a
lot with my teams naturally is
constantly remind the team of the fact
that we are going somewhere it's a
feeling in the room and so David bford
told me that when he could get that
feeling into the room of we're going
somewhere because those 1% gains the
easiest to find it's hard to find a big
gain in any Pursuit it's hard to in what
you do and what I do finding those 100%
gains it's an accident focus on the
smallest things find it enjoy the win
together which is like oh my God we just
made this 1% better there's a trackpad
glued under the table you're at right
now and the trackpad is there because me
and my team just found a 1% gain last
week where during the conversation with
someone sometimes they say amazing
things and I want to write it down and
just remember it because that might be
the title the thumbnail the description
or whatever and then after the
conversation ends I forget forget it my
team come up and say what do you think
of the episode I don't have any notes
because I've had to pay attention so
you'll see a trackpad under the table
where you are now can you feel it is it
there maybe it was the trackpad They
removed yeah there's a little velcro
okay trackpad that we yeah that was the
trackpad so all I do is I just tap it
with my finger and what it's doing is
that system underneath the table is
listening to every word we say
and it highlights it so the AI will
highlight it and send it off to my team
so afterwards I have all my notes and I
just got to tap the bottom of the table
good idea let's do that it's a great
idea but but anyway that's an example of
a 1% gain we found as a team and when we
did that we shared it with the whole
team and and we enjoyed it and we're
like this so awesome and it created that
impression that we're going somewhere we
made progress today that's Point number
two so you need to challenge yourself
need to sensor Forward Motion number
three I'm going to say is um I'm going
to say you need to be pursuing a goal
in your life that is subjectively
Meaningful goes back to what we said
earlier if you interview all members of
my team and there's hundreds of people
across different companies but if you
just focus on the podcast team where
there's 25 30 people every single person
will give a different reason as to why
they work here Holly will say it's
because of this I'll say it's because of
this will will say it's because of the
creativity and his love of production I
don't care what your reason is as long
as you got one yeah so you haven't got
to give them all the same reason you
haven't got to align on reasons they
just got to find theirs and you've got
to help them find their reason so that's
Point number three the if the goal is
feel subjectively worthwhile to you
number four which is super backed by
science we just touched on it a little
bit is autonomy and control feeling like
you have control and autonomy of your
work when people don't have that in
their work physiologically they're more
prone to disease um psychologically they
have tons of um really difficult
challenges um so having control and
autonomy over what you're doing is
integral to feeling like a free animal
that's not in a cage and last one maybe
the most important of all because we can
all recount on times in our lives when
we had the previous four but didn't have
this one in the job and the work sucked
is you've got to be working with a
supportive community of people that you
like um and that makes all of the other
ones better makes all of the other four
better notice that I haven't said you
know I haven't said a particular career
or a particular you know job or anything
if I have these five things in my
profession Steve will be back balanced
and I've applied these five things to
psychedelics where I worked for a year
invested in the company at Thai we took
the company public um at a big valuation
in June 20 2021 I believe um I've
applied it to hu to my businesses to
marketing to software with third web um
I'm applying it to podcasting I guess a
business uh I'm applying it to DJing I'm
applying it to the event businesses we
we run um applying it to my production
company which we're doing shows on the
BBC at the moment
um so the the the subject doesn't matter
it's less important than what people
think I think everyone in this room and
everyone listening to this now could be
could find their passion in a multitude
of Industries if they had these five
things the subject matter is less
consequential because I wasn't born to
be a social media CEO yeah didn't exist
when I was born so how could I possibly
how could that possibly be my passion
but I have these five things I've had
those five things for a long time hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye